so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect yo what's up everybody i am
thomas dopezio whatever you want to call
me i am here with marty o'neil what's up
folks what's up guys
uh this is the dope as usual podcast
we're here to talk about life problems
drugs accomplishments and everything in
between today we have a very well two
very special guests
host of hawk vs wolf this is jason ellis
and tony hawk how you guys doing hello
hello hey what's up yeah they talk about
drugs tony this oh that's the one thing
you picked out of all those subjects i
knew it because that's the one that
doesn't fit
i'm like go ahead ask him
oh that that that's one thing i even
asked blank i don't want to smoke these
jokes let me ask them first
that was that was polite of you i just
don't want to
ruin someone's day
like i don't want to ruin his day
do what you want
let's do it
or whenever you want you know already i
grew up in the world of skateboarding i
am quite used to people smoking weed
around me it's all right
yeah but i it also i look as a guy
that's always smoked the weed and tony
has not i've always been um
back the bus yeah i just feel like i
feel like he is really easy going but
you know you can get somebody contact
high and if he's high and he didn't want
to be and it was my fault i
even if he's like ah relax i'm fine i
feel like a [ __ ] idiot because i'm
like dude
i don't like to i've got a co-host on my
other show the jason l show and one of
the co-hosts is the touchiest
lightweight
weed person ever at one point he told me
because i used to smoke weed in the
studio he's like i can't do it dude you
give me contact high and i was like okay
fair enough i'll get a vape pen
and then every now and then he's like
i'm getting contact high from the vape
and i'm like
okay i'm gonna have to [ __ ] disagree
i don't even know if that's possible
but i don't know so that that's always
kind of the way he is i just i assume
that all potheads are that all people
that don't smoke weed are like him and
that if you smoke weed in front of them
it's offensive so i i don't do it my
thing is my it's more like oh here's my
beer drink my beer it's the same thing
it's like i don't want to be a part of
it i'll just walk around there and smoke
a joint you don't drink no i'm saying
like if someone doesn't drink and you're
like drink this it's the same thing as
smoking a joint in their face it's like
they don't want to be a part of that
yeah i just at least walk off a little
bit that's what i just feel bad that's
why i like to ask prefer or kids too
yeah i don't smoke around kids or old
people kids show up i [ __ ]
dust that thing straight away and if my
friends keep going i'm like hey put it
out get that
out now kids and old people i don't bump
offensive music around either i [ __ ]
hate it man i wish i could say the same
my kid listens to the most offensive
music ever i don't even know what it is
but it is [ __ ] offensive how old's
your kid 13. i took him to the barracks
the other day for my son's birthday and
he had a friend
in there in the back and they were like
can we play music dad yeah of course
gave him a phone you know have at it and
then it's just
[ __ ] n bomb [ __ ] suck my
dick [ __ ] i'm like
and then i look i look in the mirror and
look back and they know the words oh for
sure oh yeah i'm like dude you did not
just say
can you guys not say that in the back or
even look like you know what it is i was
embarrassed to listen to [ __ ] like that
in front of my parents they don't have
that yeah yeah i'm a different dad he's
like dad's a maniac he'll appreciate
that i know this words even though i i
did not
i just like whatever kids
i love how you can be shocked
[Laughter]
i've known him for a long time
when did you guys meet
know like i met him before he met me
so i met him in australia because he
came to australia to do a demo and he is
tony hawk and i'm
sponsored by the skate shop that um had
him there so i found out that the bones
brigade would come into the skate shop
before the demo
so i was in the skate shop
tony lance uh
steve student
nah nah that was this is later i didn't
see you until the 90s i think
maybe late 80s but
mcgill i think but they were in the shop
and they just looked around like oh cool
shirts cool board and i'm just standing
in the corner going get the [ __ ] out of
here and then they left and i was like
did you guys know who that is one dude
said no and i just flipped out on him
i was like you [ __ ] no no tony orc is
you idiot get this guy out of the shop
i was freaking out and then i met him in
the contest
but i didn't want i have video of it we
we've posted it before oh yeah it's
funny his dao was so he
he got how was it your dad just paid for
an entry yeah 25 bucks
and then it was a pro contest they put
him in the last seat
which is with me and christopher
because there's there's five heats or
something there's six back then but um
it was me christian yeah everybody
just all the banging and stuff and me
and i was like his dad's filming him and
he's
i i don't remember because i was too
focused on trying to skate but but he's
looking at his dad like
yeah are you getting this yeah he's
standing right next to me and then he
looks my way and i'm like
i don't want to get eye contact pretty
good it's pretty good um so that was
that was like 88 89.
um oh yes you're just starting out well
not just starting out i was he he was
already fairly super efficient fairly
new i would say right um i was in the
sort of
swing of my
first go-around of pro skating which is
the 80s
swing i love when you say it like that i
mean it was i i've kind of lived through
two cycles or three cycles of popularity
so
um so i it we we thought we were living
here you know we were living large
skating was big as far as we knew we
were traveling the world i was going to
australia yeah um it was packed you know
everybody ever biggest crowds you've
ever seen everybody was freaking out and
then
uh around
91 92 everything just fell off for
skating for for skating mostly our type
of skating which was more vert based
that's right when i turned pro too yeah
but also all the parks were closing so
you know skating survived and went
through a revolution of street skating
and tricks and things like that but it
was pretty underground because a lot of
people that say like well your your
career
it might have been your career that died
then but skating didn't die i was like
yeah but
skating was
was not cool was it was very difficult
to make a living even though you're the
best street skater at the time
you know what i mean yeah of course um
but it went through a whole a whole
evolution and then
came back like
i'd say like 97 98.
well that's when i was going hard like i
was telling you before we started that
yeah my mom gave me she she has a
thrasher subscription since like 91 i
was a baby and she started just giving
them to me and that's when i was like
look at these [ __ ] dudes jumping down
rails yeah and i was there was me on my
curb remember i told you my little try
to do a little board slides and 50 50s
little fat kid i tried my best man i
really did try my best did you get hurt
all the time i just was telling you when
you started i was done like the last
time i i played i was at channel with
smacked the back of my head or my
tailbone i'm done
like there's only so much and i just
started doing drugs that's like i'm it's
really what happened the drugs took over
man
selling drugs
but he managed to skate through it yeah
that saved me oh all my friends because
there was many times there where i was
like i'll just do more blow and i was
like if i do well
i won't skate so this has to end
so good saved your life many times many
times yeah no i have friends that kept
going and obviously everyone's skating
and we're all drunk my god let me try
again but i never got back on man until
i ate [ __ ] in front of jaron and that
was the legendary yeah wait recently
on here and and uh he was that was in
the doing a little demo for him oh hey
[ __ ] yeah i thought it broke my tailbone
video
but then it's a win-win
[Music]
oh
and it pans over and it comes back it's
on the ground well i remember it and it
hurt and then i had what fabian alomar
on and fabian's wild as [ __ ] we were
supposed to go skating and then i was
watching conor mcgregor break his leg
i'm like oh you know what i don't think
i want to go skating with him that was
the night before right before i was
supposed to go with him like hey baby
i'm good
i'm too heavy bro let me lose some [ __ ]
away and then we'll go [ __ ] skating
um so you guys met a [ __ ] while ago
you guys have been uh i mean i guess
friends for a long time
okay were you smoking weed your whole
skate career yeah
i don't know if it's a gift or a curse
to me it's just more about
monotony and pain you know if i smoke
weed i'm in less pain if i smoke weed i
can get in it's harder to get in the
zone but once i get in the zone it's
hard to get out like once i'm high and
sweating and focused
i mean it's different for everybody but
for me i felt like some of the hardest
tricks i ever made
was high sorry
is that true yeah like at plan b all
those tricks that took me a long time to
do like i would try it for a couple of
hours and and not make it and then go
smoke weed and i had those little
cullen and i had those little mini bikes
so i would just do laps around the
parking lot high
and then clear my head and go in there
and take me a little bit to warm up
because now i'm super high but then i
would just look i'm not leaving and
that's amazing it's easy that's
impressive i think so all right i think
i uh one i was getting del mar one time
everyone just smoked weed in the parking
lot not everyone but there was there was
a pretty hardcore crew
and i went out there and i was like yeah
come on i'll smoke with you guys and
then i went and skated and
hung up on every trick
like every time i tried to do an error
i'd hang up and i was like this is not
for me getting hurt
like hanging up slamming i could feel it
coming like i could you know i was like
why can't i
you know hanging up not not bad because
i could sense that i was there was a
problem
you know what i mean i mean you're that
high i knew it's not for me no weed
yeah i mean it was it was in that moment
very much so i was like it doesn't help
my skating
and it doesn't and and
i think that was probably a turning
point because
when i would see my peers do it
especially other pros i'd just be like i
if that's going to wreck my skating and
i am so hyper focused on my skating
and and like the events that we go to
the the practice sessions the event the
the competitions i just be like no i'm
not doing any of that stuff because i
see that some people it seems okay for a
lot of people
they don't come back
or they get worse
and that was a dread for me he was a
great ambassador because he was one of
the few that
was sober and but not preachy sober just
just sober just i'm like how is he that
good what does he do
he doesn't smoke weed
there right after that yeah i was like
interesting i wonder if i could do that
or any any any of the other varieties
yeah which intoxicants you were taking
right and when you hang out with the
guys that do do it it's super apparent
that they're not that good the next day
yeah because they were up with me until
four in the morning doing rails like
it's not gonna and you'd see them it's
just grinding rails i was always i was
always in the early practice sessions
usually because i want to get there and
get going and i would i would purposely
be in those practices because i knew
none of those guys were going to show up
oh wow they wouldn't too early they too
early and then they would all try to
squeeze into the later practice sessions
and just cause chaos and the
organization to be there oh yeah i was
like i already i skated at 9am i'm done
like i'm ready
to valedictorian i never thought of it
that way i think i mean that's what i
there's one friend of our whole drug
addict group that did not do drugs until
his homework was done and he is a
[ __ ] doctor now until his homework
was done then he raged yes every day
that doesn't count as a sober one just
so you know i'm saying he's the good one
like you did you guys were like [ __ ] it
i'm not even working listen he had his
priorities straight yeah
the only one yeah but he's the only one
that's a doctor though thomas grew up in
the meth capital of america
so a lot of my friends live outside like
straight out attic type [ __ ] but he's
the only one that made it like good
so it's good i mean i understand that
person that type of personality yeah um
so my first question after this with
this intro is a
hawk versus wolf how did you get i mean
you know each other obviously you guys
doing the same
sport
what made you come together and go
because i saw you had a show on sirius
for a long time yeah but do you know how
i got that show no
a long time ago
before that show i was 2004. oh in 2004
thank you i was asked by a guy named
tony hawk if i wanted to be a co-host on
his show on siriusxm xm
and then he told siriusxm i think jason
could actually be pretty big in radio
so
they gave me a dj gig
as well as being a co-host on his show
and the dj spot got really big really
fast to the point where those fans were
calling his show
and they were trying to do a bit of my
show on his show and this is back when
tony was way more
uh
for the younger generation like it was
people would call and be like how do you
do it keep flipping and you tell them
you know and then people would ask me
like hey man like you know i got a
[ __ ] mean [ __ ] fart recorded you
want to see it and i'm like
dude that was not that was a team that
was a tame request
this kind of stuff we would get
it was super inappropriate on the radio
yeah it was so serious exam you can say
that stuff but i would see the calls and
be like oh i don't know that call looks
like all right let's go for it all right
and i could see that was happening
and and then i was like look i think i
should just try to make my own show and
tony has always been
uh
like such a big help to me like in my
skateboard career radio pod nail pop
podcasting everything he always helps me
so it was like can jason be bigger uh
and does he have a real shot at making
it i believe he does so who cares about
my show you go do your thing dude so
there was never any good harsh that's
the way it works though
[ __ ] functions right so then we did that
for many years he still did his show i
did my show my show got bigger and
bigger and at one point it was doing
really well
and
then something happened
they got some more people or somebody
got someone else became in charge and
then we were not as popular as we
once were
and they let him go for just
disrespecting him for
i don't know how about ideas right now i
left
right but because they were just like we
don't they're not putting your show that
was a sunday or something yeah my shows
were usually thursday afternoon one time
yeah and then and then they're like oh
we put on sunday at two or something i
would i didn't even know and i was just
and this is before they had streaming
where you could go back and watch listen
to the show this was like live shows so
yeah you missed it and then and then i
said well that sucks like i got seth
rogen on the show yeah and he was
pulling crazy i got pee wee herman and
and like paul rubins i always talk about
pogba you got everybody i got and then i
was like
you guys aren't even
promoting it or
and you didn't even tell the fans you
moved the time slot it's crazy yeah
exactly and so and so i just said like i
i love this but
you're not i'm not getting the support
and every time they would renew the
contract which is whatever i wasn't
getting a ton of money anyway but they
would never offer more it was always
like maybe a little less
wow do less and maybe maybe less shows
and then finally i was just like i
i can feel what's happening i'm out and
so i willingly left i don't have hard
feelings like scott greenstein got me
there i love scott and some of the dudes
the director like the music directors
and stuff we had a good run but then it
was time to move on because i was just
like
there's no way that
the stuff that i'm doing especially with
the guests i was getting
that can't just be discounted no yeah
right and you can't just overlook it
every year yeah and so then
he started his own thing podcasting
yeah well then i go i got i didn't yeah
i didn't leave i got let go i could i
don't mind yeah there was like a a
budget thing and i was one of those
people up there with jenny mccarthy that
was making i was making a lot of money
that was the other thing this turned
into a
really amazing for me uneducated [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i was
i never would have imagined that my
paycheck would look like that every year
and so i'm very grateful for it but then
out of nowhere it was just like hey we
don't have it i'm like wait what i
thought we were doing a 15 year
celebration and arnold schwarzenegger
was gonna call in
i'm gone and it's like i know it's
really bad and we don't you know i mean
we'll try to make it up for it to you or
whatever and you know
i've got real friends there but in the
end it's a business it's corporate and
uh when it comes down to it they'll cut
your head off without without batting an
eye so that happened and i freak out
panic mode get a podcast
what's everybody doing in podcasting
holy [ __ ] is this gonna work still and
then tony called me and said do you want
to do a podcast with me
and i was like [ __ ] yeah i do that
sounds awesome and then
it was weird because when we started it
it's just different what we used to do
is nowhere near as good as what we do
now something happened maybe because of
the years of us hanging out
it's just it's always just if we don't
have a guest i think the show's better
without the guests because me and him
just start talking about stuff that
i can tell everybody's freaking out
about it we trigger memories and they're
usually if you care about skateboarding
at all in your life you're like whoa
because i feel like
he says stuff where i'm like now a 12
year old where i go what no wait in 19
what that what [ __ ] you know it's
super exciting
i just went over the lance mountain
episode and there's a lot of that
it's pretty good yeah like when he
invents the [ __ ] eggplant like i
realized
and i go whoa
you know because i it's a trick that
means so much to me and he's just so
blessed oh yeah i might have invented it
i might if i invented that
i would have it tattooed on my chest
with like double fingers
[ __ ] you guys [ __ ] inventor of the
eggplant like changing the game i think
i think that the reason it got better
too is that
you became a better broadcaster
obviously you do yeah but but i well i
did through doing those interviews yeah
but also just less reserved because i
was always like i didn't want to defend
anyone i didn't want to really get into
any weeds of stories and stuff she's
different now and also we were trying to
get music in it which was weird too
because everyone had these different
musical so we're all making fun of each
other's music yeah [ __ ] roasting each
other totally yes music is the worst
it's insane
oh no
no i i
it's not only metallica let's put it
down okay so it's the worst according to
him
i've i've
broadened my horizons oh mega death big
i was the second eater
anthrax slam you know no no no i like
other stuff now i like soul music these
days i don't really this is all metal at
all music's great yeah it's good to me
because i didn't catch it the first time
around so it's all new and fresh to me
i'm excited about
ridiculous people that died many years
ago
they had it i didn't know that soul and
doo-wop they died a long time i love
that [ __ ] man that's good man it's good
it's been it's crazy there's no cussing
in that [ __ ] makes me feel different
yeah a little bit
sometimes there's stuff they say you
don't have to cuss to be offensive
that's true there's a different time
back between the lines
yeah there's uh
man what's her name
there's a girl she used to go out with
miles davis and all these people and
then she had her own
uh out like music for a little bit and
she talks about
you know
treating a man the right way and it's
like
oh damn you didn't say sucky's [ __ ]
we got it yeah i got it you're really
gonna you're really gonna nail that
thing when you get it home got
it so when did you guys start the show
uh has it been a year
uh
i think so yeah it might have been a
year yeah yeah we don't care about that
it to me it's because i got i started i
started skating again because now i
don't work it serious i i don't have a
five-day lockdown oh you stopped skating
during the [ __ ] i said i stopped skating
for like 20 years pretty much oh what i
skated once i skated
i think it took like a seven year break
did a backside of 540. so i skated for
three days to do a backside fight on
your 40th birthday my 40th birthday then
stopped again
and then uh i went and got stem cells in
colombia and it kind of
tightened my knees again and i was like
i wonder if i could skate and then i
started trying every now and then to go
down there and then i
ended up tearing this uh piece of my
knee off
the last
an mcl i just ripped it clean off and
then i went in there and got a
a uh cadaver
knee replacement
so yeah put dead one in there yeah
cadaver ligament yeah yeah yeah not a
whole one it's just a partial one and
then like carbon fiber and all this
other cool [ __ ] in there kevlar and it
[ __ ] makes it work
so now i can skate and fall off and it
doesn't hurt so now i've been skating so
we do a show together and then i skate
and most of the time it's just him and i
i'm skating [ __ ] tony hawk's ran with
tony hawks my [ __ ] it's part of my
job almost like it's the greatest that
was that was a big feeling i mean i got
her a couple months ago but um that was
a big part of of the beginning of the
show too is that people were seeing the
progress
we would talk about it but we'd also
like that was the bulk of our social
media for the show
was our skate sessions right
um that's i mean that what goes hand in
hand yeah watch the podcast or listen to
the podcast but but you could but it was
fun to see
jason coming back and then he would set
a goal and everyone's like rooting him
on and we'd shoot it and
it's been emotional yeah like i've done
some stuff where oh you know he told me
on the i did a kick the bendy and he
knew i'd been trying it and i guess he
was at a a family event when i made it
but there were several people there that
filmed it so people start sending it to
him when i made it i really tried not to
cry but i i felt emotional enough to cry
because
i knew how long it had been and i know
how old i am and not i don't feel safe
yet on a skateboard and i was like i
just [ __ ] want to do it so bad one
time you know and i made it and i was
like it just brought all the
the memories of all the work and all the
all the [ __ ] that i've been through to
still be here and do that and then i'm
driving home and he texts me it's just
like
no way
and i know that i know that means that
he's seen it you know and he and then he
told me when was the last time he did
that and i said in the tour that we're
on and he goes dude that was 20 years
ago
so then
you know i'm driving down the freeway
and i'm like 20 years
and i i could still do it and it's more
fun now than ever because
it doesn't matter if you like it or not
i don't care if anybody films it or puts
it out there i
wanted it i want to make it so bad i
just wanted to have it and it was pretty
cool
i know
on that same subject
uh
he went it was on a it was on a weekend
so there's not usually sessions
happening at my ramp on weekends and it
just happened that some people got
special permission to go
and there's a japanese girl yeah that's
sakura yesterday she she's the gold
medalist yeah the little girl no no no
from the park from the parking lot the
olympics she's a little girl though make
no mistake yeah yeah i mean but she's in
her early twenties or something but oh
she's a sheep i think so yeah wow or
late teens anyway but just funny just
because
this was way before the olympics you
didn't know who she was and just like
this random japanese girl is the one who
beared witness to his first gift of
bendy and she's totally rooting him on
like yay yeah like she came over to like
congratulate me and i was like
who are you who are you thank you
you're really little
are you sure you should be touching me
like i just felt like who is
she's she's one of the she's she's
probably the best female for skater it's
crazy how good girls got lately yeah
yeah i noticed a lot a lot really good
yeah like this the park and street is
like i'm like oh my
you can do everything yep it's it's
incredible and then the ver not to
mention how good they are how many there
are
like i love it and they're all upbeat
we're all having fun everyone likes
people skateboarding is way more
friendly now i don't know if that was
because i was a part of the bad part but
it just seems like everyone's like cool
what do you do now it's just everyone's
style or everybody's choice of whatever
you do is appreciated and i think in
their like 80s and 90s
if you didn't do it a certain way you're
going to lose friends
oh [ __ ] yeah like i couldn't take people
serious if they did certain tricks a
certain way i couldn't even really look
at
you get you'd basically get canceled for
doing oh no [ __ ] yeah
like what's an example of that
okay uh
i'm trying to think
i'm not saying names uh
sometimes there was a person that uh
young up and comer and he started going
really big really powerful errors and
stuff but when you do a frontside air
that's when you're turning this way your
back leg your knee is tucked under your
forearm
and if it's not tucked underneath your
forearm then you're taking a [ __ ] in the
air
you've got both legs scrunched up and
both knees pointing out like that it's
it's like grabbing around your leg or
grabbing between your legs between your
legs it's stink bug now
that's a sensational maneuver and good
for that guy he's ripping but then i was
like get the [ __ ] out of here
what the [ __ ] did you're that good and
you can't just put your [ __ ] knee in
like what is that stop doing shits on my
face
that's what it felt like makes sense
i was so offended i got you
yeah so i don't know if he was canceled
together just for his sting bug front
sitters but nobody no i'm saying in my
mind
people and i had group and i had a group
of people that also agreed and once
again no names but i know that there
were certain tricks done in front of a
certain group of people where i didn't
have to say anything
he did that and i'd look over at my
friend and he'd be like yep
[ __ ] that guy
i understand man everybody has their
things but you're saying now it's a lot
more friendly i 100 agree i see nothing
but super positive i love the follow
i've
i love it man i don't think i've loved
it more it's really weird to say
okay i think about it all the time but
when i think about it it's never
in an aggressive manner anymore somebody
sent me a photo
yesterday greggy sent me a photo of
myself and tom boyle on the top of a
vert ramp
in a demo
and my face
i'm so pissed
and i'm like that's just your look
that's the look when you were really
trying to skate hard you're like
you know like
who you angry who did it you mean like i
definitely had a bone to pick with
somebody and i couldn't put my name on
it my finger on it so instead i just
stayed angry but
yeah it's great to be here therapy and
all that stuff i fixed myself sorry i'm
happy yeah sometimes i'm happy for
absolutely no reason that's amazing
that's what everybody [ __ ] shoots for
i don't it's not it's a rare rare
situation i feel yeah and then to be in
this when you're happy with just being
doing nothing and then now you're on a
show with tony hawk and you're skating
again and not to mention all our friends
that all those guys are down there like
i've been i'm friends with these dudes
for 30 years
and we're on the ramp and we're all old
and we've got kids and we're like sore
and more tired and we're all
i'm like me too man
he's like man like yeah that's what
we're we're like
funny it's funny
now especially
when you are skating with some friends
and you sense that they're winding down
yeah and there's a sense of relief
and not like not like
oh man you're all done yeah that's why
you oh dude yeah good yeah you're wait
you're done yeah yeah i could be i could
be done sure yeah yeah yeah i could
usually call it if somebody else calls
it yeah
i'm just going to walk down the stairs
not drop in we're done
[Laughter]
hey what's up guys thank you so much for
watching this episode and we just want
to talk about one of our sponsors this
is expressvpn before we start go to
expressvpn.com forward slash yola when
you use our discount code on their
website that code right there will get
you three months for free and if you're
tech savvy you already know expressvpn
is the number one rated vpn site example
when i log onto the internet my internet
service provider can see every single
thing i did online but when expressvpn
is enabled on your computer it doesn't
let them see any of that it's
essentially like going to the bathroom
and closing the door you don't want
anybody else to see what's going on so
expressvpn gives you the opportunity to
have a secure encrypted tunnel straight
to the internet and yes you're on the
internet but your service provider can't
see every single thing you're doing and
just take advantage of what you look at
and sell to ad companies and then they
target you phones routers laptops
anybody that is connected to your wi-fi
in your house has the expressvpn
protection so once again go to
expressvpn.com forward slash yola and
that's going to give you three months
for free it's easy turning on a light
switch and know that you're protected as
always from marty and i thank you so
much for supporting the brands that
support us back to the episode
you guys do this so i mean that you have
to pay me [ __ ] half a million dollars
to drop in on a [ __ ] vote ram yeah
because
it's not going to work out for you
that's like saying you know i mean
someone should pay me a half a million
dollars to show to block a car
because that's what's gonna happen to
you a hundred percent it's different if
i i don't get paid half a million
dollars because when i drop in i just go
wee
literally that [ __ ] sounds so
wonderful you could do it we could teach
you do you know that tony and i are some
of the greatest skateboard teachers in
the world
bobby lee we told bobby lee how to skate
in 15 minutes
i'm not joking um
uh we helped a blind guy do a frontside
alley disaster on the quarter pipe i
mean he was basically responsible for
that but still counts
uh
ryan sickler
turned into a skateboarder
yep in about 15 minutes
uh we helped michael tully my co-host we
had kevin kraft skateboarding who else
have we got up there
uh
i don't remember on the show i feel like
we were just so far that's what we've
done on the show but it's different if
you go there with just tony i would not
advise that because if you look at his
resume of people that he's had there to
drop in it's not good
oh you mean that they failed yes he's
got i've got he got you said we teach
people to skate not just drop in and in
my defense yeah those people came saying
i am going to drop in and i
usually discourage them once i saw them
try it on a smaller ramp you did try to
discourage
the okay so the dudes from the slow-mo
guys yeah i was gonna get the footage
too i'm not that's
i don't think you're ready for that and
you said that yeah but he knew that it
was probably gonna be a slam and that it
was gonna be good yeah right uh big boy
yes big boy once again you guys want to
watch that you want to watch it it's a
350 pound man oh
jumping off the top of tony's ramp into
a shoulder block onto the flat
yeah he that he made the loudest noise
that's ever happened on my ramp yeah
and
then the strangest noise out of his
mouth
but it wasn't even
like someone that got the the air the
wind got off him but in this really
primal like scary way i thought he was
knocked i thought it was chaotic oh okay
the way he was doing it so it was scary
but but he was okay um
but i could tell that
when he wanted to do it he he dropped
into the smaller ramp first we have a
five and a seven foot behind our ramp
not a lot of uh step progression beyond
that like it goes from seven and then
you're up on the big one 13 and a half
yeah
and he was dropping on that i could tell
he was kind of going in straight leg and
i kept saying oh you got to really bend
your front leg until the board hits the
wall then extend on the way out and he's
like so just commit
he said
that's not at all what i said
[Laughter]
he's like all right tony
one upstairs he's like just commit right
like no no big [ __ ] and then i was still
talking and he just went
he you were trying to give him advice
and he dropped he was he was just tunnel
vision it was like i'm going to go up
the ramp when i get up the ramp i'm
going down it's not a bad
theory to just decide you're going when
you get there because most of the
drop-in is commitment that's my hardest
part but there also is a part of like
but skateboarding involved i want to say
there are there are dozens of
examples that aren't on video that
aren't on youtube or anything of people
dropping in based on my advice so thank
you very much okay no i believe that i
believe he said and i will say i did get
tony hawk's had a kickflip on [ __ ]
tape or dvd oh trick subs trick i had
that my grandma bought it for christmas
go grab i know
[ __ ] i don't know how to kick flip but
they can't and i watch that [ __ ] i
practice on grass for like three months
oh man did you get it yeah i got it
eventually yay see it taught him how to
kick flip okay okay you're better in
your face in my face indeed
i was like 11 i remember i got it for
christmas
[ __ ] grandma yeah i remember that
[ __ ] but yeah i did learn how to kick
flip from that video yeah um that's good
because my kids are not that good so i
did i don't even wanna
trash if we had a kickflip race right
now you might beat me
yeah pretty bad
you know beat me not pretty bad real bad
i mean i figured you you terrible
straight skating street okay because
it's a different technique when you're
skating convert and it's even a
different it's a different way to flick
your board
oh completely different yeah and i just
never i got hurt a lot so i just never
was able i can't run very well so if i
have to fall off i just have to body
roll or skid
and that's like
i don't know i've got like three of
those in me in an afternoon and then i'm
like [ __ ] off you know i'm not gonna do
20 of these i won't be able to walk the
next day so so people that skate do you
is it like one or the other street or
like vert skate or is there like people
do both some people can walk the line
yeah most people but people now than
ever more than ever yeah because the
skate parks are the great equalizer
there's all kinds of the terrain is so
um diverse that they can figure out all
the other ways but but in our generation
and
the generation that followed you kind of
chose
ramp skating or street skating yeah
and very few people could do both
because it was such a different style
too yeah like the way you have to it's
kind of like you know like a
uh muay thai fighter fighting a wrestler
you know like they both you don't [ __ ]
with either one of them but they're both
coming from a completely different angle
they stand different they just way to
put it like i'm flat-footed on vert on
street you're on your toes
so it's more pop all the time you got to
be on your toes on vert you kind of need
to be
stuck to the ramp when you're on it more
so to get that speed so the more flat
footage you are a lot of guys that go
really high
have a
very solid sit-down stance so then when
they when they ride the ramp it doesn't
even look like they're working that hard
and they fly around with ease
but it's only a certain kind of person
and usually that person linking you
waiter not a great street skateboarder
but when he's on the vert ramp holy [ __ ]
it's like he's got an engine in there
but on the flip side of that if you take
a really good street skater and put him
on the ver ramp
they they pop in a way that's they're
popping off of the wall the way they
would pop off the ground instead of
going forward you need to go up right
right so so a street skater goes onto
the ramp and pops all the way out to the
bottom
oh that's why you see those people kind
of bail at the very beginning is that
what i'm talking is that
if you pull out too far yeah you bail
straight if you're popping yeah but but
you always see it with c skaters they're
like they go they get near the vert and
then they snap their board off the wall
and they're way too far off the wall and
lands so convert you're just letting
yourself roll you're not popping at all
at the top pop it but it's like more of
a it's a vertical pop that
keeps your momentum going upward
not out if you do it right there's less
energy in it yeah you're just flying
like if you do it enough you just fly
around it's way more weightless way more
a feeling of flying really and you're
going faster too so yeah it's like
adrenaline you know
how do you guys feel about the olympics
they just they introduced it that's why
i was bringing because i watched that
little that little little girl went
first place which is awesome i mean
she's badass but
um
this is the 15th street the streets oh
yeah yeah
who's that
uh that was momiji right
i'm not sure she was such a yeah well
over 13 i think yeah and then racia got
second or third okay racia is like the
i i think she's the future of
street skating in terms of
female or in general like she is amazing
you might you've seen her race yet she
she got a viral clip of doing a heel
flip in a in a tutu like in a fairy
costume yep
yep now she's
she's like probably the most popular
athlete in brazil
oh yeah for real what about uh ufc
fighters
like who's more you know what i mean
because i feel like there's a ufc
fighter or two that are brazilian that
are suits
yeah like amanda nunes is probably
really or what's the guy with the
scouring i guess
my mind went straight to soccer so i was
like she's the most popular athlete
she's more popular than soccer players
because i would say that soccer stars
would rival mma stars in brazil for sure
right so yeah wow
damn hell she's she's like 13 correct uh
i think she's closer to 15 or 16 now and
she got she gets she got tall right
before them but way taller than she was
um but she's yeah she's amazing it
sounds like you
yeah a little i mean except you're a
dude you know
she well i mean you mean when i got tall
yeah well you're really good and you're
real little yeah and then you got real
tall and then you got real good yeah
yeah because now the big rails are not
as intimidating as you can get on
everything and she doesn't get broke off
when she
when she bails out
rocks she had such little legs yeah she
did it was rough
because that's you know
in the olympics too there was there was
a big obstacle
with one big rail or solid-sized rails
and and the
people who weren't as tall
were risking everything yeah you know
they weren't gonna
they're they're not gonna straddle it
they're gonna get destroyed right
so it was a it was a big deal when they
hit the rail i think they got extra
points for it too fair smaller i i mean
for hitting the big rail as small i
don't
i don't know if you're approaching it
and when you're approaching your head's
lower than the rail before you pop up
it's pretty gnarly
like yeah i got you on that one yeah
like if i'm trying to ollie onto a ledge
and right when i crouch down it's like
you know here i'm like i'm not getting
up that yeah yeah
it's a that's a no yeah so um you said
for 20 years almost you didn't skate at
all
um
yeah you're not skating like not even
getting on a board at home or nothing or
just completely i skated the venice park
a couple times but i never put pads on
and skated like because to me it's just
skateboarding skating a vote ramp i like
all the other things but
if i'm gonna be serious the one that is
the real thing is avert ramp to me so
i didn't pad up for
maybe another seven years or something i
just took you know i scared one time
which doesn't count to me because i
didn't do it with any fun i was just
like you got to make that you said
you're going to make it you're going to
make it i made it and it was so
frustrating and so difficult i was like
[ __ ] i knew i hated skateboarding like
that was the worst
note to self don't try that again
because that was you know i was trying
to do something for the people again
and now
it's just time i feel like i had a
bitterness towards not being as good
anymore
and i just couldn't face it so i was
sort of
negative to it or just try to block it
out because it was too painful to
realize that i'm not in it anymore
because it's my life it's what i am but
i'm living in hollywood trying to be a
radio guy like so i was just weren't you
getting into like jiu jitsu and [ __ ] too
yeah oh that was the thing to fill the
void that's what i was wondering like
there's no vote ramps in l.a so i
started training mixed martial arts yeah
and that's why i started fighting
because i so badly wanted to be back in
the because when i started skating again
that's the other thing i realized it's
[ __ ] so dangerous
dude it's so [ __ ] gnarly
like it's different to me now you can
totally break your leg
i've heard of that happening to a guy
yeah once or twice just i didn't think i
feel like maybe because i'm older i just
sense it more now where i'm like man
we're [ __ ] crazy do you know that
we're crazy because we're flying around
i'm old as [ __ ] i think if i hit the
ground i still bounce up
but it's just way less of a percentage
of confidence when i when i'm
approaching the ground at a high speed
i'm like is this it
you know
but so far it's really uh that's the
thing it's been baby steps and tony's
been helping me but you know we've
skated a bunch of stuff where i've taken
some heavy duty he skated we ski the
backyard pool up here
a few months ago
um this is a pretty famous pink motel
pool
um
we got we got the golden ticket to go
ride there for a day and i told jason
yeah i want to go check it out and then
he came in hot
and
tried to do a grind and went way over
the coping and just did a backflip in
oh yeah i landed on my fingers and it
like broke my did something to my
knuckles where they're like permanently
[ __ ]
something happened there it was the
worst slam i've seen at the pink motel
pool yeah and i'd only just been i'd
probably been scared for about six
months so and that was the first bowl
like i've been skating tony's and i'm
still like yeah not that confident and
i'm like i'll just take it easy at the
pink motel and then i think i made one
grind and i was like oh it's [ __ ] on
that's just [ __ ] it's rip into one
and then whoa i'm like why are you
upside down
pain tolerance for you guys is up there
yeah i just just you said i broke my
knuckles like i would [ __ ] be done
i'd be another profession breaking my
hand like that breaking my leg like that
it's practice the more you do it the
less it hurts
i mean he fights too though so i was
like all right that's that's true you
just know what's gonna happen you've
you've been there before to me it's more
of a it pisses me
off like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna get a [ __ ] hospital get a
good yeah
that's exactly how i feel really it's
not the pain it's more no it's just yeah
it's just a hassle yeah it's the pain is
nowhere near as bad as the hassle it
takes to heal it yeah i mean that's
pretty much my first thought when i i
knew i broke my leg right when it
happened and my first thought wasn't
like holy [ __ ] oh my god it was just
like
[ __ ] are you serious like i gotta cancel
this it's gonna be months
and then someone tried to move and i was
like
then the pain set in
yeah what's the worst injury you guys
have had that was it that one yeah i was
there man that was
it's gross it was gross as [ __ ]
i don't want to talk about
um i broke my pelvis too but that wasn't
as visual or do you think being knocked
out
uh probably with the pain yeah
yeah i broke my pelvis and got a ko at
the same time when'd you do that uh 2004
i think 2003.
in a monkey suit that was the ramp right
yeah that was for that was for wild boys
yep
no helmet [ __ ] yeah that was bad um but
this one
yeah this one for sure i mean i came
back from the broken pelvis in two
months
wow just i'm sitting pelvis you can't go
you can't do yeah
for the first few weeks can't do
anything if you're gonna sneeze you do
everything you can to not sneeze
it's the the sneeze is the most painful
thing could you do a poopy
uh they give you it was more getting to
the bathroom was the hard part walking
well
you you're on crutches basically oh so
this is where the hassle comes in i get
it now yeah that's not one day it's like
temporary yeah the hassle's four months
yeah but but then on the other side of
that like last year
um i dislocated my fingers
these two
and
i kind of knew what i did but i and and
so i just went to the hospital and just
said i think i just threw my fingers
took an x-ray
doctor grabbed him put him back in
later leave yeah your hand's fine moves
all good no pain um yeah my knuckles are
fat though
from breaking them can't go all the way
what's that from breaking them
no just because it uh it took so long
for me to get to the hospital for him to
put it in place
that it just kind of builds up all the
calcium or i don't know
oh god but but but you know you don't
like
you turn you you learn to adapt to what
your kind of new normal is after you get
hurt right
yeah you know
you're not supposed to be you compensate
for it and then that's just that's just
you
so like i know i did that to my fingers
and i know that like i can't make a fist
the way i used to
but i can function and do what i need to
do so that's fine
that's why you guys are good friends
like this you relate to this oh yeah
that pain that broken hand i think
that's why you guys show you know what i
mean like
that's why you like doing the solo
episode so much you have someone to
relate to all this crazy [ __ ] you do
yeah most of our guests though are kind
of on the same ilk
and so they get that but but it is fun
for us to just do our own thing and
catch up and
because when you're doing guests you you
start to lose
what's been happening in your life 100
we call them solos yeah yeah we do one
uh one a month yeah and it's mine it's
catching
catch-up episodes that's that's when we
get demonetized and [ __ ] with youtube
because i'm saying some stupid [ __ ] but
that's the guess episodes it's more of
like
i have a guest i have company and when
you're not it's like oh facetime you
know what the [ __ ] i did today
that's meeting him for three hours we're
talking [ __ ] and that's when we take
mushrooms to get [ __ ] up and you take
mushrooms on the show we have a few
times it's it's uh he had to do the ad
reads i couldn't [ __ ] function hey
can you talk like are you a talkative
guy when you're tripping oh for sure i
just okay i just have to like i don't
have that much to say when i do that but
when you guys but you guys do play them
back for yourselves yeah we watch every
on monday on youtube we premiere and
we're in the live chat for the episode
so we watch with the fans every week
so i'm like all right
get ready i kind of i don't see it until
it drops i go that's what i said oh my
[ __ ] wait you don't remember what you
said i mean are mushrooms how many
mushrooms do you take i don't remember a
lot
i've just been taking uh caps how old
are you 32. i guess it's i'm good i've
taken a lot of drugs i can't take a lot
of mushrooms i got mushrooms like micro
dose and stuff every now and then i got
i just tried it micro toasting it's okay
i usually take seven grams that's mine i
don't like getting intense anymore i
love it
if i'm a little bit giggly i'm like cool
that's cool but i don't really like
to go into the [ __ ] secret room and
i'm like no that's exactly what you want
to go to the secret room i don't even
want to know what the secret is just let
me go back to the couch you [ __ ]
[ __ ] i hate it
oh no we're going to get on tv
i hate that that's how they go man one
time i it was before we was legal i had
a weed muffin in my bag and i was
getting on the plane i was like oh [ __ ]
i'll just eat the muffin and i ate the
muffin i guess it was a really strong
one because when the plane took off i
could have sworn the plane started to
like tip and go upside down oh
and i'm like oh [ __ ] it's going upside
down and i'm like and i look at everyone
else and no one's acting like the
plane's upside down i'm like
i feel like it is but i guess it's not
third-party perspective always helps did
you say it out loud
no no no i played it cool but my face i
just if anybody was looking at me they
knew that i thought the plan was upside
down
that guy's on drugs he could always tell
yeah i kind of like just started close
one eye i mean just like maybe it is
maybe it isn't what am i gonna do
yeah panicked yeah edibles i've only had
one time where i blacked out off black
hat on edibles i did like like three
four thousand milligrams that was a lot
so i was like
4 000 milligrams
yeah but i blacked out on that why would
you do that
that's what i do man
yeah r d exactly r d for our company
how much can i [ __ ] do
so you can write it off exactly right
now for tax purposes
i keep my receipts my cpa go what is
this it's weed like all right it's good
that's what you do [ __ ] yeah
fourteen year old man i gotta
when in the 80s when i was making money
and
there were no taxes taken out of
anything so it was all 1099 income and
i had to get super creative with my
expenses
so
if i got a haircut
yeah it was like it would be your image
yeah you know gotta get the flop going
the mcsqueeb and then
um
and then cds every they go what do you
mean music i ski to music and i and i
told the tax man that i
do choreography to the music
okay yeah
but it's true sure but i mean anything
you know a camera yeah i need to
document the tricks and just sure yeah i
wanted a new picture for you know
promotion
so hold on because i don't know like
could you give me just a quick rundown
on you're just you're a young kid you're
abnormally good at skateboarding and
then you're the most famous skater
you weren't abnormally good that's the
thing i've learned from hanging out with
him lately
he wasn't he's just normal and he put in
the work so people miss that you know
you think sorry tony to answer a bit of
your question but he's
i thought that i've always thought you
were just like he got on a skateboard
and he just [ __ ] flew around like it
was magic and i was like son of a [ __ ]
must be crazy but the more i know about
his childhood it sounds like he just
went there
and obsessed over it and put in the work
right yeah i think well definitely in
the beginning yeah though no one would
label me as natural i was just super
skinny and couldn't get any speed and
looked all lanky like my arms were just
flailing
and then uh
as i started to figure it out i started
to create these little tricks but most
of them were under the because we skated
pools so most of the tricks i did were
under the coping
but then i eventually figured out how to
launch myself even though i was small
and that was the breaking point because
once i started doing all these weird
little tricks that i could do under the
coping above the coping people were like
what is all that right and then that's
that's when i got
that's when i started doing better in
competition
and then as i got taller then i started
going way higher
and doing the the
what at the time were the hardest tricks
and that's when i started doing really
well in competition so mostly with like
i would say from age 10 to
12 was pretty painful 12 to 14 like i
was starting to come into my own
and then sometime around the age of 16
is when i really like
hit my stride
were you always really ambitious like
did you want to be great or was it
skating was so small i wasn't that i was
aspiring to do something i've that i had
seen before so it wasn't like there was
anyone that was rich or famous from
skating yeah that's true and so the idea
that if you're a good skater well you
could you can be a pro skater until you
turn 18 and then you got to find a job
so i was just going hard
doing the best that i could because i
loved it so much
thinking all the time
when i graduate high school i got to
figure out what college i'm going to go
to or what job i'm going to get and that
and i won't
not that i was going to quit skating but
it was just i knew i would eat into that
time
and i got lucky that around the time i
turned
16 is when things started to turn around
financially and all of a sudden at age
17 i was making 100 grand a year oh [ __ ]
and bought a house while i was still in
high school i read that
that's crazy so were you traveling for
these competitions yeah they were mostly
in the us but there were some
international events a lot in europe
if you went to an event
there'd probably be a
few thousand people there yeah
no but not a stadium not no we're not an
arena yeah like now it was weird to me
because he was always
everyone over there was the best and
gigantic and the most famous person that
i could ever imagine meeting but the
world had did not know that you know
like this was my little world where
people were like tony hawk who's tony
hawk and i'd be like what the [ __ ] how
do you not know who tony is the other
thing is is when you say you know were
you bit it wasn't on tv or anything yeah
yeah right so it was all just this
underground movement it was like it was
full counter culture and there were
these videos like the bones we gave
videos and other videos that people
would pass around yeah but you know it
was barely in movies barely on tv
and so to us it felt like the biggest
thing in the world
but in the grand scheme of
success and sports
success and celebrity and it wasn't
anything not on the radio yeah even
close yet no but it was huge for us i
mean it kind of made it cooler in a way
because nobody knew no one even knew
well my mom brought me up in that [ __ ]
so she was always really heavily she
showed me my first skate tape like the
first one i ever saw and she gave me all
the thrashers and [ __ ] i don't [ __ ]
know the guys were eating [ __ ]
that's all i ever they were like
kids they were kids and i saw like this
kid's like [ __ ] 15. i'm seven i could
do this and that's when i was like i
need a board and i remember i put my
first one together i was so [ __ ]
excited i think the cool thing about
our
nowadays is that
uh kids can choose to skate as readily
as they choose baseball or basketball or
soccer or football
but they also choose to do it in
addition to other things and i think
that is sort of the the tipping point
for skating in terms of being here to
stay because when we started skating
that was it if you chose skating that's
all you could do because you were
instantly labeled an outcast you were
not going to be able to you were not
going to be able to hang out with your
mainstream friends or whatever or do
their sports
and you were marked and we loved it like
it was fine that we were set apart we
found our community there we found we
found our sense of purpose but nowadays
it's much more available
to do it casually yeah because there's
skateparks everywhere because we for us
like you had to be on a mission to go
find a ramp
yeah drive hours to go skate somewhere
or it would be a couple of people yeah a
couple people right and now it's like
every sk go to any skate park right now
is packed
right now right
yeah you just made me realize how many
weird people i've met at like random
little
concrete piles of [ __ ] in the woods
loading dogs some [ __ ] dirty stinky
dude there with dreads like man [ __ ]
yeah enjoy and i'm like what the [ __ ]
who is this guy he's got like a couple
of tricks that i've never seen anyone do
before they suck but it's just like i
don't even i've never even seen anyone
else skate this is how i do it and i'm
like
there's there's all kinds of [ __ ]
jungle creatures out there it's awesome
watching people that are not influenced
by anybody
but i've it's that's pretty rare these
days when it's a skate spot now
everyone's everyone's there you know and
the parks are so good
like things that are available now off
the side of freeways
they just didn't have that you know
right there on neko park that one right
off the freeway that
hidden little gem i don't know if you've
seen it's right behind echo park it's
just a ball a ramp a staircase and it's
enclosed right off the freeway like with
a gate over it i see like kids breaking
there all the [ __ ] time what's that i
know what that is it's pretty cool
forgot the name of it
it was just it's surprising
stuff there i don't know you got it yeah
you what you have to you have to pay or
sign up get your pad so you have to wear
pads there right i'm not sure it was
full of trash
when i moved here and then a couple
years ago i'm driving down the freeway
get the [ __ ] out of here oh maybe maybe
it's not the same i'm thinking of i'm
not sure it's right next to like right
across the street from mango park where
to go vertigo park that's not it i'm not
sure all i when i first came to america
the first thing i ever skated was a um a
mini ramp that had uh hips and a spine
and to me i didn't want to leave like i
could have stayed
and skated 24 hours like i think i could
have stayed awake all night because i i
was like
wait you can put a you could i didn't
know you could do it let alone see it
and it was just
in and then to know now like me coming
here now and going yeah look at this
concrete
i think my [ __ ] eyes would fall out
like i don't like to know there's like
burp balls this ball pool skatepark
corner that's like just everything and
some stuff that i might oh i didn't even
yeah that's a good idea
you don't like this park there's one
across the street yeah that too got that
one what's these pump hump places do you
see those oh yeah pump tracks yeah pump
tracks i'm like man what's that just
it's concrete
with bumps in it and turns and you just
like motocross when they do that thing
in the race yeah but instead of skimming
it on a skateboard you got to pump each
one of them to keep your momentum gotcha
so it looks like you just you can pump
it right all the way around you don't
push yeah
but coming from i've skated a few of
them and coming from a vert skater's
respect perspective you pump so hard
through them that you get way too much
speed for the turns you end up running
off the course oh so you have to keep it
in check
okay so you've been warned okay when you
go to one watch out cause you're gonna
fly off the course all right i look
forward to it
one of my questions because you were
saying now you can go to any park and
ever when i was a kid like i said my
mom's like thrasher here you go and then
i'm watching x games i'm watching all
you guys [ __ ] fly around bob barron
quest and all these guys
then the [ __ ] game comes out
playstation one and that changed
everything i think for the younger
generation it wasn't because everybody
loved video games and now there's a
skateboard video game so when
[ __ ] pro pro skater came out
that i was telling marty when we when we
booked you guys i'm like wow
what a pivotal piece in my [ __ ]
childhood playing that [ __ ] over and
over and over again because it was you
know playstation one's the new [ __ ] it
was n64 or you know it was dreamcast or
sega so then tony hawk pro skater comes
out and i'm you can pick different dude
i watch these guys in the [ __ ] x
games like when that came out that was
right after that 900 correct it was
really close yeah same year same year
yeah it was really because i remember
i'm sitting there watching like what the
[ __ ] is going on there's two kids in my
school that skated that was it i'm a
little bit of mexican town look there's
one mexican one white kid that skates
and we're friends now because you skate
too
so when that came out i think you're
saying that you can't even be around
anybody if you can be a skater you can't
play a baseball player anymore you can't
play football you're the skater kid now
i mean that i feel because i played
football i played soccer and i skated
i feel like that game kind of opened up
a lot of the
you don't have to be a [ __ ] pothead
or you're selling drugs at the skate
park kind of thing i feel like that game
kind of helped out a little um
definitely no thank you i think i think
that
what it did was bring
a an audience that
was curious about skating but didn't
want to participate didn't know anything
about it
and brought them into the world
and helped them appreciate it and it
actually kind of it kind of created
a spectator sport
from from that was so that those people
that that played the game really enjoyed
it they would sit and watch x games and
and know the tricks
and be inspired by it and and and a lot
of kids end up trying
actually starting skating because of the
game 100
i hear that a lot and that was not
something i ever anticipated like when i
said when i said i'd do the game i just
wanted skaters to buy playstations to
play it because i knew that they would
be stoked on it yeah to me that was the
big success would be like oh skier's
gonna be hyped on this thing and then
it blew up in the gaming world and then
suddenly kids were like i want to i want
a skateboard i want to learn a
skateboard i want to do the 360 flip to
crooked grind because they can do in the
game
and it gave
other pro skateboarders more respect in
the game because i've always when people
ask me what i do when i say it depending
on the year
there's you know people go wait you can
get paid for that and then after tony's
video game came out
you would you would say you're a pro
skateboarder and they go oh wow do you
know tony hawk and i'd be like yeah
but it's not it's no longer i can see
that the look on their face is no longer
this dude's lying and he sells weed
it's more yeah of course you are because
i'm well aware of skateboarders uh doing
that for a living you know so that kind
of put us on the map as it could be a
career stop [ __ ] on me
that's what i felt like your career
stopped [ __ ] on me oh i wish i would
have said that i love that what do you
do i [ __ ] get high and
film it
you could pay for that yeah [ __ ] you i
love that thank you um one question i've
always had real quick before we get out
of
here
i've all ever playing the game how do
you pick who's in the game
um
he's my friend that's that guy's good
that guy's good i've always wondered
because nfl you know who the [ __ ]
going to be in the game the new tony
hawk yeah holy [ __ ]
uh well for the first game i just i
wanted an eclectic mix
like skaters that represented all styles
of skating so not just street not just
vert well-rounded and characters
like chad muska i mean he was you know
he was an amazing street skater but he
also he was such a personality and we
knew that that would add something
special to the game
um
so
yeah and you know i was trying to be as
as inclusive as i could too considering
the the
the population of skaters at the time
um
and so i the amazing thing about i mean
i do i guess to give myself props
almost everyone in that first game is
still actively skating
and still considered relevant
that's true you know and i'm really
proud of that fact that we picked the
right skaters to represent
skateboarding in video games
um and then going forward it was more it
started to get crazy because we still
have to fend people off
oh i can only him you know once we got
to like the third and fourth game it was
like
everyone wanted to be in it and just to
be like okay how do we navigate they're
all asking
oh yeah wow yeah absolutely i mean it
was an honor it was amazing
um i was a hidden character in one yeah
yeah american wasteland
which one was that
third one
uh
no it was um
it went underground underground two
and then america was crazy to hear
he's thinking about doing flying through
the [ __ ] secret glass door in the
first one or oh man i played that game
every [ __ ] day in the grand theft
auto so you guys are green suited like
we had franklin from gta and he was
telling us kind of the whole process of
how they film how they like film the
video game like that so i did mocap i
did motion capture for the first game
and it was such an ordeal
then because it's like night it's 1998
or 99 so the technology wasn't really
there and they set up all these cameras
skate street
they set up all these cameras at skate
street
and oh yes um with the bulls
yeah and then i got to put the suit on
with the balls and and i'm telling you
all this because my board hit one of the
cameras
and they had to reset the whole thing it
took like four hours
um and then when we they got the the
footage they couldn't really use it
they couldn't use it for the game the
way they had programmed the game already
what like it just didn't it didn't it
didn't translate to the way that their
engine was
so they ended up really just animating
everything from video
that's kind of the dirty little secret
so
my motion capture was used a lot for
promotion
you know so a lot of people like
people you guys saw that i did that yeah
and they thought it was cool but we
didn't use any of that data yeah it was
cool
that just really popped my bubble tony i
was thinking about it what the [ __ ] is
going on but but so it and and the i
guess the best example of that is when
when i did 900
at the x games that was in june the game
was already being submitted to console
manufacturers so it was it was already
done it was done oh [ __ ] and then i hit
up the i hit up neversoft literally the
day after and i said you guys i
did this trick
last night and i think you're going to
want to have it in the game considering
that people are going to probably expect
it now
um
and uh i got an email back from the head
of of neversoft and he's like we're way
out have you we're way ahead of you you
[ __ ] rule
yeah
and so they animated that from video
from video from the x games like they
just changed
it's just the same [ __ ]
yeah in the game well they they didn't
you know they they use the body language
and everything but they didn't it's not
they could digitize the videos but um
but they did i mean
to for them to get that into a game that
was going to be released in september is
unheard of
especially around then
so uh i was lucky that i was paired up
with neversoft and activision i mean
changed my life
it's mine too [ __ ]
do you play video games um oh i mean in
the 80s
i was uh when
when we were doing all the thps stuff i
was only playing that because i was as
soon as we released one we'd be on to
the next one
and
trying to you know work on that so
um
i didn't really get into other games uh
these days i mean i'll play like i i
play a lot of mario kart with my
daughter nice but now she's kind of out
of it so
and she beats me now so that's fine
we can put that one away
i used to be good as a kid i [ __ ]
suck i played the other day dave and
busters
my car good anymore man i can't throw
those banana peels like the best thing
about mario kart especially with having
kids of different ages is that the
techniques are pretty much the same
so you're always the king
when you're the dad yeah i guess mario
kart like i play mark harp before they
were born and then as they were all born
the systems got better but the controls
are pretty much the same and then i'd be
like oh yeah let's go okay and then
finally katie and i played it so much
that she got better than me all right
i played supercross with my son that's
that ended supercross which one is that
um
it's it was the one that had the atv in
it as well
mx atv unleashed i think damn dude i
don't think i played that watch i played
it it had a super cross track and you
could do whips
over the triple so it was pretty legit
it had like ricky carmichael in it and
[ __ ] i liked it i had that the game too
extreme the only other skateboard
biking
i think rollerblades were in that game
that game fell off when searched yeah
i used to drink surge this isn't pretty
1998 right now sorry guys um so my last
question before we got here
do you guys think with the show i mean
you said you integrate your most of your
promotion for the show is you guys
progressing and doing your things and
tricks like you said with jason
do you think you'd ever do
integrate live show with some type of
skateboarding event because i could see
a lot for the podcast
yeah sure yeah
yeah i would love to do that we just
we're you know we we need the resources
and the and the support team but yeah
i'm in the middle of doing live shows
for my podcast so once i test the waters
and do that then i'll probably know more
about how you do podcasts at live
uh so i'll let him figure that out first
yeah he's busy if i can that's how it
works when it comes to certain things
when it comes to like making the show
bigger because tony's got the job of him
being him and i've got the job of making
podcasts because
that's my job so i i know a little bit
more and i'm always in it and i know
that if the json show does a live show
everybody goes i go
birdmate
got a spot you know and yeah and he's
got a ramp
so it's just like a matter of getting
sponsors and all that stuff but
he'd one side would have that all it'll
be like hey it's we can do it and he'd
be like okay we'll do it and then it
comes down to time because
he's doing a lot more [ __ ] than i am
like he is busy all the time
i agree
i agree with that it's crazy he's here
no but also you're gonna eat at a
restaurant or something is that like did
you plan your day at least
yeah i know i'm going to the
why are you going to
i got invited to the i think i think
yeah i got invited to the dior runway
show oh for santa monica tonight that's
what you're doing okay
they even give me clothes oh
you boss i knew you'd love that god
what'd you get you get shoes
shoes yeah
you already
uh i didn't see any he's like i just
looked at all the [ __ ] up this morning
they gave me a
one of those man purse things not from
my outfit no do you want it
i already gave it away oh
[ __ ] come on man i'm your ma i'm a man
puss man oh damn
well you know who saw it first
because he came to my office
jared no
who it's all right oh galena galini oh
yeah well that's fair
okay fair enough
but what i was going to say is that
the other part of that when he he is the
one when people ask us to be on podcasts
like you guys i just let him vet it
so it's like is that cool yeah it's cool
all right let's go
you're welcome so here you go
you were vetted
[ __ ] you're out there doing stand-up
comedy too right yeah yeah i just did
the comedy store last night oh the
second time i've been at the comedy
store yeah how's that man it's [ __ ]
amazing it's the i once again i cannot
believe how
lucky i am you know i just to have a a
situation after all the things that i've
been through and now i'm like i have a
shot at being a comedian i don't really
care about i got a job so it doesn't
i'm not the same i'm very lucky like
these people are starving they're trying
to get spots and they're trying to get
you know a couple hundred bucks a thing
and i'm like you don't even have to pay
me dude i just want the experience i
want to get good at comedy that's all i
want from it if people go and you're
really funny and they come to a show
[ __ ] yeah that's really cool but my main
objective is to master it in some sort
of fashion you know where i know
i can go up there for an hour and you
know everybody's like wow that's [ __ ]
hilarious that's what i want to do
that's my mission so it's been going
pretty well i did one on
friday at the comedy store and then tim
dillon who i've never met who i love
comes up to me and he goes hey man
you're really funny that was amazing i'm
glad i didn't have to go up after you
and i'm like is this [ __ ] dude for
real and he's like do you want to do a
show with me next week and i was like oh
yeah so then that's what i was doing
that was [ __ ] hilarious yeah he's
funny as hell yeah he's a funny guy too
this guy opened up for whitney cummings
oh [ __ ] dude that was my second my
second gig in front of a lot of people
was with whitney like
i don't even know how that happened in
san diego i wasn't 1300 people in a
theater oh damn it it was terrible i was
the most
i was like scarier walking onto the
stage [ __ ] flying through the air oh
walking on stage by far scares the [ __ ]
out of me not so much i'm a little bit
better now but then
and how big that crab was i this i was
like whoa pressure like
high levels of pressure i'm giving
myself right now i was really new i
didn't even i was trying to make sure i
remembered my set because i didn't
really even know it yet so it was very
stepping into a whole new profession and
that i get it i get the nervousness but
now that you're getting it done that's
why i was asking you're on stage once
you guys do that you're i mean you're
obviously you've been doing stuff for so
long on movies and tv
this live show is going to be [ __ ]
cool i i don't know i'm just
that's what i'm seeing see he knows yeah
because he knows more than i do about
this whole game and if he's like this is
exciting if you and i did that that
means we're doing it 100
i thought you guys didn't say anything
because you're like [ __ ] we we're gonna
announce tomorrow
i thought that would work
to executive produce it
okay
no better person on earth
dude i'm telling you uh that's yeah
that's what we do we uh entertain oh
[ __ ] you sorry we'll do a stunt too you
could do that car stunt you drive a car
and i'll jump off that girl off of it
yeah you're gonna drive a uh uh
like a side-by-side like those buggies
off a jump
and then i'm i'm standing on the outside
of the car holding my skateboard and
then when he jumps into the air i in the
air i jump off the car and land on the
ramp next to the car and we both ride
away
it's it's a stunt that he attempted but
the
all the elements were not quite there
yeah didn't work yeah i hit my tailbone
so hard that my [ __ ] my poo hurt for
like two months
i feel like i broke my
buttholes
it was a deep pain it was one of those
ones where you hit your ass so hard
that you think you might have hurt your
back
you know like for a second when i was
bouncing i was like oh have i you know i
mean i started doing that and i was like
okay no you haven't done that like
that's how hard i hit i missed the ramp
completely
jumped out of a car
and
the ramp was like on on the wrong angle
and i was like [ __ ] it we've got to try
and make see if i can get on the ramp so
as soon as i leap out of the car i'm
like oh
because i see the ramps on this angle
and i'm still going that way and i'm
like you got to be [ __ ] me like what
am i dead again and then you know i had
to i just went my ass
well bam and i was like
this is it i could barely walk for a
couple days and i still did the stunt
the next day like
20 times i tried to do it i kept
bouncing off when i'd land because the
bank ramp was really banked it wasn't
like it's the dedication
it's the dedication with you guys yeah i
don't have [ __ ] out and i'm talking
about it for the rest of my life i
almost died the other day guys that's
why i did it 20 times the next day [ __ ]
that
yeah but if you say you're gonna do
something that's true and he's willing
to do it again that's all that's you
that's hold it for that's payback i'm
definitely gonna do it and then
my [ __ ]
will be redeemed
[Laughter]
so that's all we want me and my [ __ ]
that night i'll be like
well done we got that guy back
next time they'll know better don't [ __ ]
with my ass so the first hawk and hawk
versus wolf is going to be
sorry
if he's going to jump off a [ __ ] can you
do that at the end yeah the whole show
would be a good idea to do it it'd
definitely be jumping out of the [ __ ]
we shouldn't do it at the start that's
for sure
it might be a short show oh [ __ ]
i'd be [ __ ] my pants all over a ramp
yeah skateboarding i'm gonna stay here
i'm staying over here thank you guys so
much i appreciate it thanks before we
get here where can everybody find the
show working everybody like what day
what time
oh it gets released on mondays yeah so
sunday midnight most of the time yeah
but hawk vs wolf wherever hawk
vs wolf
i mean it's on youtube it's on spotify
podcast spotify we've got an instagram
same thing hogwarts
what's our instagram hulk it's at hawk
vs wolf yeah yeah
and yeah we got it yeah we got that
there you go
we're not really that keen on that part
we're more like trying to we're like is
the show really good i'm blown away that
the show is really good every time i've
been doing this for 15 years it's my
life and ever we don't prep
you know and we just turn the mic on and
every time i walk out of there i assess
what we did and i'm like
i've [ __ ] been freaking out how good
we are at this like we're it's a really
good show whatever i don't care if i'm
too horn it's not me it's him like when
i'm by myself it's not that good
when we're doing it together a couple of
times when i i was laughing so hard that
i i really couldn't function anymore oh
yeah i was crying which makes the job
you know the deal dude when you guys are
laughing it's like the best dude deep
feeling it's the best [ __ ] there'll be
some time to take this off and go
what the [ __ ] are we doing here that was
awesome yeah oh yeah it's the it's more
fun when you like the [ __ ]
you're talking to yeah
that's for sure that's what i want we
avoid each other in real life
i actually hate this guy he's the worst
wait until they turn the mic off he's
going to start kicking everybody he's
very mean i'll be out of the door before
you put your headphones off
well guys thank you so much for being
here yeah man thank you appreciate it
thank you so much thanks appreciate you
guys um
yeah i think that was that was good that
was fun guys i appreciate you guys being
here marty
i'm just really super grateful we can
make this happen thanks for having us
yeah thanks for having us thank you guys
both for being here appreciate it all
right we're gonna get out of here as
always guys thank you so much for
watching this has been the dope as usual
podcast have a dope as day
nice that's the least amount of weed i
think i've ever smoked on a smoking
episode sorry no i'm saying but i'm high
i need to switch up my wii this is good
[Music]